yeah yeah yeah it's Wednesday Brendon
shops on his way to Syracuse where
there's a foot of snow and I got Bobby
Lee dick in the house and it's yo this
shit's about the pop Andy what are you
doing first of all I'm trying to get on
periscope am I allowed to do that Andy's
assistant who's a good-looking young man
named Isaac who's in very good shape
came in in essentially why don't know
how you describe it for you it's like an
elf meets at Richard Simmons meets such
a Captain Kirk but he's also athletic
yeah I like your body dude I mean II
know I suck it off Andy what's up do you
put two DS on kid
no just one connection to pour what are
you trying to do
periscope are your periscope in the wall
about Andy's wearing a short white shirt
on camera we all see it we are but yeah
some people just listen and a tie it's
adorable you work as far as the ac/dc
Andy what's going on get off your
computer man try to set this up you
jumped right in what do you trying to
your periscope thing oh yeah oh God oh I
see I just think Bob is wearing a ski
hat great shirt you always just
described what everybody's wearing are
you being sarcastic you don't like my
shirt I think you're shy light or I like
it too
it's money what is it about our
generation what is it about this
generation our generation where people
are wearing like it they would be almost
coastal dress hugger Hey yes you shut
the [ __ ] up if you guys get on cursed
communities mom boy we did it we did a
bread than I did a podcast of Mike Tyson
and I would say it was exciting but but
Mike breeds like Mike some knives every
time we'd be doing here Michael
all right he's just a heavy band yeah he
probably has like some deviated septums
yeah from getting hit you did a lot of
boxing right Sharon have you ever been
in a fight
yeah well I've been knocked out you have
like five times cuz you've gotten drunk
and gotten in people's faces no no no no
not that at all so act like it don't act
like that's well the drunk parts right
but then people blindside me they hit me
in the back of the head behavior from
the side hi if they were coming at me
straight on there's no there's no fight
they would lose what would they would
lose you know my dad was a boxer I
didn't know loves boxer five stage
doesn't mean you you know what okay say
it to my face
dude you're already getting ornery I
hate ya what I know you know what you
knew we said to me out there what I
could Brendan Shan what's his name sob
sob trying to shop shop dude Baba yeah
sha Shan because I go British I'm
filling in for DeSean and then he goes
oh I'm leaving do you not say that oh
because you have a crush on I love him
yeah I'm in love with him he's Iike who
is it yeah he's a purchase and did he
not be here because I was gonna be here
no he's in Syracuse doing stand-up Jesus
your Q's doing his put what I show you
you know what they call him we call you
know what we call Brendan you hungry
eyes because people who look at him have
hungry eyes you know what ching chong
said to me when I came in here so sorry
but ching chong goes you know my
remember to change at all ting ting tong
ting tong said that I misused and I felt
really weird about it
why because it was a kind of creepy in a
creepy way you know me like we have some
sort of like bond are you both the same
Asian yes we are you're Korean
how dare you Bobby he's acting like he
knows you do you guys know each other
yeah well then how come you know mrs.
chin me on a me on an air comment comes
up me down there you don't speak male
what we don't now to no mojo man we dine
aside that don't come up
let them speak yeah yeah really good
stuff guys thanks man
why don't you use Asian to describe all
people from that part of the world
that's a lot of people it doesn't make
sense who decided that that was
politically correct Asian could be
Russian Asian can be either by Johnny so
that it's true like what sometimes
Indians go well we're not Asian you are
yeah they're not though the ancient
Hawaiian could be Asian yeah yeah that's
Polynesian which is Asian do you know
the Chinese were the were the most
people on the planet until recently you
know just where the supercede and
Mexicans Noah no Indians in the last
couple of years they call it a
subcontinent don't they the Indian Sonya
and like one day and when they had
Indians have the baby sometimes they
have like another nine arms thing no
that's not true
yeah they have like these mutations and
they have benign arms nuts and everyone
worships them they're like it's a god no
and then we're human I love India let me
just say something right now all right
there is a TV show that I watch okay
it's called bizarre know what he's not
even listening thank you so much this is
[ __ ] [ __ ] man then you can get us
all to yeah hey I was gonna ask you
Brian so I called Brian called me and
said don't come at 12:00 come at 12:15
then he called again said actually come
at 12:30 which helped me yeah but you
said it was because you had to do some
reading yeah some reads commercial oh
okay I didn't know you I'd be so funny
I'm doing my reading I I know you're a
prolific me you love read it I take my
reading from 12:00 to 12:30 I love you
all say that I've I so long to be an
aristocrat like I'd so long to release
of all well I'm taking my rest at
between 2:00 and 3:00 and I take my
exercises of course in the morning I
want to be that a person my ex but you
do read a lot to read a lot like every
day yes Wow
I wanted to read you read Bobby I read
our self-help books
yeah anything by Eckhart Tolle living in
the moment know that cart droll no but
the power of now you never read it
no but I've lit tried to listen to it
while I was driving yet on his died his
voice is just so he's just hoarsely if
you want to meditate or take a nap press
play it's so true and and also I'm the
power now which I read a long time ago
is basically water down Buddhism you
know yeah it is it's like but I'm really
a really good book now called humility
is the new smart which is by these two
these two professors who basically are
talking about how automation is going to
displace about 80 million American
workers so robots forty-seven percent of
the work of our workforce is not gonna
have it gonna have a job with artificial
intelligence a grub oh yeah and she
basically here in this she and this man
wrote a book about the mindset you have
to have in the next twenty years if you
want to compete in this world which is
basically well so the idea it's like
learning a lot and accumulating a lot of
knowledge you know you see well you have
a lot of knowledge in your head that's
here relevant because smart machines can
do that so much better than you yeah
what you need to learn how to do is be
pliable and someone who has the ability
to learn unlearn and relearn and that's
really difficult yeah yeah no they can't
think outside the box though Oh like
like robots and machines
that's right can't be creative right in
that way that's why that's exactly was
saying that yeah learn unlearn dealer
like fox mulder for instance right you
know fox mulder know either CIA FBI
agent from the show x-files oh that guys
sure about what's Mulder yeah yeah and
uh you know he comes in a woman was
murdered right Oh David do cut wait what
wait what yeah because the Fox Mulder
Fox Mulder company in real life but he
sees a murder right and and Scully's
always like maybe you know a black
person did I'm just saying I know that
black lives matter I'm just in this
scenario usually it would be a black
person usually it would be
no but I have Korean against them and I
love them okay
don't write a letter or nothing okay in
this scenario let's not even use the
black eye okay let's lose a Rob Arina
afro-american alright so an
afro-american would be like oh like I
probably killed this arm this person and
then Mulder would be like or a wolf
alien and so computers can't do that
right yeah cuz they can't think outside
the box what I'm saying I'm refuting
your premise that's what she said you're
you're actually you're I know bolstering
my premise which is that it's you know
that we will learn that we ought to be
better at critical thinking creative
thinking and collaborative thing yeah
can I say something about that yeah and
it's about the Millennials no the
Millennials I noticed this guy here
you're 22 right Isaac and then my kids
they're 20 22 and 28 they don't and
which is weird because they're
Millennials they don't embrace new
technology they're like no no no no no I
like to like talking into your phone
when you're driving yeah a text like
just press you can just look down for
half a second press the mic and go I'll
be there in 15 minutes and then and and
send it you know without having to tie
to be in a commercial where it's like
this is my daughter's last text I'll be
there I know it's so Joseph died yeah
and they don't embrace the newest newest
newest newest technology because they're
set in their ways where we do don't you
guys use that I don't know I think
you're making a good point because I
think that's one of the biggest things
that human beings suffer from as we get
caught in one way of doing things here's
the other thing human beings do a lot
they tend when when somebody agrees with
you you'll tend to look at them and
think of them as smarter than somebody
who doesn't it's very natural for us
because somebody does you think you're a
smart ass I ever yeah so they'll be like
you know you're you're right and you go
this person it's just this is a smart
bother that's what you do you don't know
I do know and all because
why Brian is smart because like for me
yeah if so many agrees with me I do the
opposite I just lied you know become a
liar
yeah I lied to win someone agrees with
me I don't trust them because this guy's
a deceiver
what do you lie about everything right
like there's nothing truthful I say ever
so so if I'm like why I got to watch
what are you minute - oh yesterday I
went to saw that movie on the Florida
movie would not William Dafoe yeah
good movie because it's you know it's
organic and it's like is this best
performance oh I agree I agree yeah yeah
that was sports when I'm around bunch of
bros who really know sports and they go
Pat's man I go
it's Belichick he's a [ __ ] genius I
just heard yeah because I have no
character yeah and I want to be low but
not only that that's just easier as a
comic I've been so used to like
embellishing things right so it's like
oh that I want to do this into a joke
but it's not funny just in terms of the
would actually happen so I have to add
little things to it that's right yeah
have you ever told the story that wasn't
yours you weren't there but it's such a
great story that you put yourself if
they wrote a book it's like other
people's life yeah because it's just
weren't fun because that way you want to
tell the story and you want people to
like you want them to enjoy it but if
you say my friend told me the story it's
not the same I want to put yourself
there cuz it's more exciting like Steve
Rannazzisi had a story about [ __ ]
his pants on a train but in later I
found out that it was a lie but then uh
sure I'm sorry okay but then I told the
same story like it happened to me that's
I said when I told the story right to
somebody other thing that's right there
and stories everyone tells so you told
me a story on my short-lived podcast
that I tried to reboot it didn't happen
it stopped now he had stopped but about
you on it really is the best story ever
now I'm thinking it's lie yeah because
it's so good you said that you got fired
from can I tell it yeah you guys signed
your [ __ ]
thing yeah well but you probably knew
mine would never air so he he got fired
from man - yeah that's of jug smell yeah
yeah but they said we're gonna give you
one last we wrote a sketch you're gonna
play Connie Chung this Friday so can you
pull it together yeah by Friday so he
did he stopped doing drugs stopped doing
alcohol but when you do that when you
slam the door shut that that quickly
yeah it's not good for your system so
here it's off stage on stage as Connie
Chung was already funny right oh right
he just got nervous his his bowels
started gurgling he was coming off of
drugs and alcohol and he just [ __ ] his
pants massive diarrhea going down his
stockings he had to he had to walk off
like this yeah and they and they fired
him for real yeah yeah can I tell you
now the embellished parts of that yeah
yeah yeah it didn't go down your
stockings exactly what then how do would
they ever know because Aries Spears next
to because you just [ __ ] your pain right
and it seeped in a little bit so the
whole audience can see it but in the
story I say it chunks of [ __ ] was in the
stocking yeah yeah to make the story
better yeah that's in that way I lie but
the premise in itself still actually
happened yeah all right as you know
court of law
would I get fine for that I don't think
so alone no I once [ __ ] my pants I had
to park my car threw on my jeans I would
no no underwear and I parked my car in
New York I couldn't find a parking space
I was walking back to my girlfriend's
apartment I [ __ ] my pants and the poo
rolled down this is this is it roll down
and it came out of my No another one
came out I remember there was girls
there were young girls in school uniform
yeah and they were on the corner and I
was and I was like if they see this poo
roll out of my pants it'll be it's
unacceptable and I just left a bunch of
poo and then I got in the hallway
another pool roll down my pant and I was
in the hallway and a woman came this way
and she goes Jesus Christ I go [ __ ]
dogs
dogs that's good and I woke my
girlfriend oh my god I shat my pants you
need to know that I wash them the jeans
I threw them away and then I went down
and picked up the poo you picked it up
yeah oh you can't leave human poo around
it's disgust all it is yeah yeah go
ahead
you have another poo poo Hey yeah well
is the whole thing gonna be about poop
though no no we move on okay you loose
Tory I just had a poo story right so
everyone with Joe Rogan well you do your
puse Tory about Rogan first and then
I'll close it up with my poo poo one
from last week well um first of all it
goes back all the way to the Ben Stiller
show when we had this photo shoot very
first photo shoot and I was doing a
cleanse and but it really was just a
fast
I was drinking just water I don't even
think I knew about the Master Cleanse
back then I was just in can water I love
the way you've been to drinking like
you're sucking a [ __ ] or something I
feel like a million bucks and they're
like we're ready for you Andy everybody
I stood up and I just passed out and hit
the corner of the counter cuz we're in a
kitchen broke my glasses black eye and
then we had to do the thing so years
later on on news radio great show Rogan
same kind of thing happened I was doing
another cleanse I think I did cleanses
right before the photo shoot together
you know spell yeah caught up a little
bit yeah and so I'm on some other kind
of fad this time I think it was the
Master Cleanse
and and we were all together and I I
thought I was farting it was a shirt and
I just diarrhea in my pants and I was so
afraid I was petrified that Joe yeah
would find out yeah because showing
everyone else where that to lead
everyone yeah everyone so I ran into the
bathroom took my he took my everything
off and then buried it in the garbage
and then just tried to wipe up and just
went out how a grody Joe was so mean Joe
was the most a grody thank you when he
was younger he was scared so aggressive
made the ladies cry it was yeah it was
weed that changed him yeah and he would
he would yell at me
you know about all that but I love him
now yeah yeah but he yelled at me in
front of executives about smoking pot I
should be so scared about smoking pot
yeah now he's the biggest punk I know I
I was I was I was afraid my petrified of
me too I made it when I was in San Diego
and we went to a strip club and some guy
with with the tattoo of tears on his
face oh yeah more than one that means he
killed people there's like four you
killed a family for I like when they do
that too so you kind of like oh I won't
talk back because you'll kill me right
one could have been an accident before
yeah what was it like Matthew Broderick
ringing like in England what he was
drunk and I killed somebody or as you
broke into his house and slew there yeah
yeah yeah you have great lawyers you
have money so you got out yeah I love
that shirt I mean you killed all the
witnesses right he was in Scotland
oh he was a scar on my back but my point
is this is that but robe we were in a we
were in a strip club and this guy you
know I don't know Rogan was getting a
verbal altercation with them you go
would you say bro that's what he said
the John goes hey [ __ ] you know maybe
there was like a car thing and then they
went to go to the car to get guns yeah I
could get guns and then Joe goes let's
get high here right and I wouldn't leave
I go you're I called him a [ __ ] oh yeah
and then he he still to the state gives
me [ __ ] about it yeah because Joe has a
really good eye for danger and joke and
Idaho Jojo can pick up crazy yeah he can
pick up dangerous if Joe tells you
somebody's dangerous he's right get the
[ __ ] out of there because he's got weird
antenna for that he picks up on the
weirdest [ __ ] we were talking one time
on the street at swingers and this dude
like he goes like this he's talking to
me we're having a really good
conversation he goes hold on guys dude
just made another [ __ ] revolution
around the block he's casing us I go
what he goes that guy and the guy drives
by him I go no he goes yeah he comes
back around again go what the [ __ ] is
that guy doing and he picked up on it he
goes let's get out of here we both got
our cars and left but it was weird it
was like why is that guy why is that guy
making three or maybe recognize Joe I
don't know but either way he picks up on
[ __ ] I would never say
see I don't I'm the opposite like if
Hiroshima happened yeah you hundreds of
years later my nuclear shadow would just
be me sitting like this running a bomb
whatever yeah scientists would look at
like a wall did you get robbed from
behind here sometime yeah yeah yeah you
got robbed I got robbed yeah
during the day at 2 p.m. and somebody
just tacked on you guys gunpoint no but
let's rob them with our bare open hands
yeah what's he gonna do and I just laid
there just laid there like this and then
they left I still laid there and you
just let them rifle through your pockets
yeah and they're are so scary and bad
was across the street and he didn't help
me
he was just watch an ad in there weak
else okay the comics don't give a [ __ ]
about each other really comments are so
solitary creatures right right I don't
help you toward you help me I would I be
lying no I went to I would be row a rock
or something nearby and perhaps yeah
that's what I would do I help ya I
really would you're the kind of guy your
jumps in yeah you're crazy you do there
was a barroom brawl a few weeks ago that
started because of me because somebody
was talking to me and getting a little
aggressive and the people I was with
jumped up and I didn't hardly knew these
people they just came over to talk to me
they were fans and I guess I had met him
a couple times but they jumped up and
started to fight this guy and then
everyone in the bar started fighting
girls were taking chairs and it was a
full-on barroom brawl and I jumped in
and I was trying to pull people off and
then I just came up with the phrase the
police are here the police are here good
idea yeah that's they weren't I don't
think you know I'm Steve Howey I love to
be hello Steve Steve's a big strong guy
about 240 64 and he's not really hearing
a peep out of anybody Steve took I love
him because he's a giant man with so
almost like a small man's intensity
hilarious and hard as a rock
cuz you're gonna have muscles but they
have to I always bring up Steve Howey
he's a beast why is it on that
a natural 240 okay okay and you and so
yeah he's a stud it was on Reba and and
and he's as big and strong as it gets
well yeah I mean there but but take a
look at this some shots you can put her
by the shape of his head yeah they're
down there look at him look at him down
there he's six four
he's probably 250 that that oh my God
look at that Bob he's big and strong as
[ __ ] oh my god what are you trying to do
to me
I know you I know get you a little meek
in the least his head his head all of
our heads could fit in his head he's a
giant man yeah he black gorgeous but so
he came to see me do the stand-up just
yeah at the Emperor how do you know him
I work with him working with him and oh
yeah yeah yeah he said he was on he's
gonna show called with with William Agee
right now shameless yeah he's on
shameless
yeah he's the guy that sleeps with the
Steve's never started working I gotta
get on the podcast he's never stopped
working he's amazing anyway he's married
been married a long time what is he
doing with his hands in his pants right
here game causes pain there's no pockets
men no no no but so so so check this out
so we're at the improv and his wife he's
been married a long time
these dudes rough looking guys kind of
good-looking table of guys like maybe
four dudes maybe five guys but they're
they're big they're athletic guys yeah
and one guy just keeps looking back
obviously the kind of guy who's used to
getting female attention and he keeps
looking back at Steve's wife and and but
he's given her the he's being a little
disrespectful he's giving her the up and
down and steve steevo old iron head he's
wearing an argyle sweater vest - right
and Steve Steve looks at the guy and he
goes and then the guy says something to
his wife no no like like Steve goes
Steve goes kidding me this [ __ ] guy
something like that oh and the guy
doesn't hear him and I and I clock all
this I gotta go onstage and then the guy
says something like were you from - the
girl - his wife oh and Steve goes hey
bro you [ __ ] stupid or something
she's with me and the guy goes you had a
[ __ ] problem and Steve stands up and
the guy stands up and Steve again
is bigger but he's with these other
dudes and they take notice they're big
and I and Steve is doing this Steve has
literally stand there like this and he
starts going and let moving his tongue
back and forth he's never even back and
forth like a Cobra
he's going like this and you can see
that it before guys gonna beat him up
but somebody's gonna lose an eye
somebody's gonna lose and somebody's
gonna be putting a can cut like in a
cone cuz he's just too big he's the kind
of guy that can clearly take a shitload
of punishment you know he's just and
he's crazy enough and he's definitely
gonna fight yeah so he's doing this
weird Cobra thing I and I see disaster
and I gotta go up on stage and these
guys are scary though and I also know
that these guys are athletic and they're
not hearing a peep out of him either and
they're gonna jump so I grabbed the dude
and I go like this I go hey guys guys
guys guys you see who is that the guy
that you're about to fight he is a
homicide detective and he's with the
LAPD and all his buddies are outside at
the bar and they can't wait to arrest
you and they're all as big as he is so
if you guys want to fight a cop a
homicide detective please do so but
please know also you'll be cuffed you'll
be black and blue and you will spend the
next five days in jail I promise you
that's my promise to all of you right
away
yeah and they sat the [ __ ] down they
apologized I have a question yeah I have
a question yes but that whole situation
could have been diverted no ow all right
so this is I think oh it's right here I
was right here right you're the guy say
something to kalila were you from this
is me yeah hey oh you would've just said
I oh she was that no I would have oh and
you would have just jumped in and got me
guys no you can't have me I'm just
saying this girl Lila's not I already
know that kalila is not gonna [ __ ] this
dude yeah there's not unless he rapes
her right another name kalila okay you
met her before that's normally I've
worked with yeah you worked with her
before but um anyway he's not gonna rape
her right then and there or take her out
she's not gonna hook up with him so
what's gonna happen so I just go I would
just go hey yeah
no one's standing up there's no lies
going on with you saying hi you saying
hi is not really that interesting to
that guy he's a wolf
yeah look all you know what this is
[ __ ] what you're saying to me right
now this [ __ ] predator [ __ ] alpha
male [ __ ] hey you and Joe Rogan and
all these guys do you I'm a survivor too
okay
yeah I'm a gatherer you're gay yes Cokie
I'll do it differently I'm gonna eat the
deer me too
no you're not and you have clogged
you'll be waiting with my food and I
want your button here and I'll do that
too we gotta live well we all survive
differently here's how I do it yeah you
said something with that story earlier
when when if I get into a little bit of
trouble I start like if I'm really mad
I'll just I'll take the person on even
if they're as big as Steve yeah because
I might be dead I probably would be but
he'd be blind
[Laughter]
oh yeah yeah not blind
I'd take them and let's get them off I
so believe Andy yes I know that you're
in trouble
yeah got your eyes though I've seen you
drunk and I've seen your energy like you
have a crazy amount of energy like where
you're you're moving at such a pace
where you would be such a handful of
fire horrible yeah yeah why are you what
are you Irish no no I think a little bit
yeah you're you're such a nose adopted
because you talk like you're kind of
like you talk a bit feminine yeah yeah
but you're also like you also have three
kids and you're also you're complicated
you're
sevens you're sexually complicated okay
yours actually compliment you're a
comedic genius and you're also but
you're also kind of a hunter and a
killer yeah oh yeah well he's everything
to me you are and it's also the things
that you've gone through I mean it's
great that you're alive and you look the
same
to me all of you can [ __ ] that you've
been through bro well I look up to you
like I can't believe he has I can't
remember I said seven but I think you at
seven fifteen fifteen years surprise
it's it's the first time you've ever
said that I've known you in 20 years I
love you no I don't know if it's a lava
no I really do I think it is incredible
I think we be literally impossible I
have to ask you do you really is it 15
years no it's so [ __ ] crazy because I
know because before I said I lie all the
time there's just certain things that I
don't lie about this one it's true
listen to me okay
I embellish stories just get this out
there I'm give a [ __ ] ching chong all
right all right I'm not racist right now
you'd of lomar fergus it was a guy the
kid the tarball know the guy that a kid
that that died on the bike oh yeah
skittles yeah what in Florida remember
that guy in a hard drive on Mar Mar
which Ava Marmara save amar ching chong
what pork and I cried a [ __ ] healthy
tear oh me too actually look at that his
parents were very upset he's very upset
but my point is ching chong he gets it
because we already have that kind of
relationship that you would say racial
things to me right not really not I
respect you so much Bobby oh my god
you're just upset
oh my god what you just did to me right
now has made me feel guilty
oh sorry that's rare and so what we're
seeing John John met
Gin Gin I'm gonna call you chin from now
on Oh Jim J hi yeah I know I'm sorry
chin chin I changed it when I was 18 to
chin cuz my friends couldn't really so
it's really gin gin yeah yeah well I'll
call you Jim say Jim wait so you've
you're sober 15 years finish your
thought what it was good you know the
rocks I know off the cuff like that
wait what 15 years yes 15 years yeah
yeah
so impressible why he's so good because
let me say something right now he has to
be
in easy 15 years no there have been many
times you know so funny cuz you say
something about Brian is that there was
a time when I couldn't get a job and I
was I was noticeable at Sibley depressed
at the Comedy Store so one day I'm just
sitting there and Brian puts his arm
around me because you're trying to
uplift me and you said to me while you
take acting class and I was like I knew
what you were trying to do you're trying
to uplift me but I took it as you don't
know how to act
yeah but that's how I took it and it
went home and was relapsed yeah but
biting my nails like oh but did you take
your classes no no I just believe in
doing anything to change things up
sometimes your life can be so [ __ ]
out yeah yeah even if things are really
really good that's when you have to be
careful because if shit's going super
well man you I think we're all used to a
little bit of dysfunction and if things
are going really well that's when I have
to worry cuz I'll [ __ ] it up I'll take a
risk although I would say one last thing
you also did which was made me go I like
Brian Cowen I was standing outside the
comedy store sitting there in the patio
I was with Natasha Leggero her Ari
Shaffir walks by with a glass of ice and
whips in her face shards of glass hits
her face right why would he do that
because they used to date and she
betrayed him fair she experienced Oh and
so he had he did on purpose right you're
the only guy to stand up and you got
right in his face
what the [ __ ] your problem and he I've
never seen him that scared because I
don't know you dude
I don't know you back off dude I don't
know you you know that was that kind of
I buy the rest a real man did well good
[ __ ] I had to say something but you know
what in in in to Ari's defense I don't I
saw it I don't think Ari meant to throw
it in her face I think he meant to throw
it in her direction yeah and I hit her
and he meant to throw it at his face
well I believe the ice and then maybe
the glass slipped but also already kind
of I think I realized that this was a
diss Randeep that yeah deep really them
and I talked to Natasha about I talked
to him and it was like
I was like these are two good people
that just have you beat the living [ __ ]
out of me during that time three times
in a row in the face for five [ __ ]
times almost Alma's died are you serious
yeah my eyes got all red and like blood
I had internal bleeding in my skull I
was going through convulsion Wow NY no
one at the comedy store help me up why I
kind of got up and I go I'm gonna call
the cops
what I mean by that's what I mean and
they go no you're not that's what I mean
by comics don't come to the rescue
remember David who has cerebral palsy
yeah somebody made fun of him this great
great guy but he had yes cerebral palsy
so he talked kind of talks and he was
acts a little shaky yeah he walks oh
that's another good one no no he was
actually a very funny guy but he had he
had visible he was visible he had
visible palsy and this guy made fun of
his stop for just a second whenever I
see somebody with this is a horrible
joke by doing all the time yeah dark you
know they're just like going down the
street like this I'm like oh my god that
guy is [ __ ] drunk in public I'm gonna
call the [ __ ] cops
that's so you're a bad person
I don't say it to him I say him across
the city you guys go fall on the car
with your healthy bodies and he's like
with your straight behind sad it says
yeah well the problems are born they're
completely lying there completely
cognizant Joe gets a kid excuse me like
a car sorry whoops must be my breakfast
no my buddy used to carry around it this
is ten years old you carry around a fart
a little fart hand fart thing and here
you go people like that me go hey it
never got off like you'd be talking like
girls he go oh it's that black box no
electric one yeah no this is something
like
squeeze the small that thing the other
thing thing but wait you were in the
middle of I I interrupt so I so this guy
made fun of him oh I like surrealism and
my friend was really upset and he
couldn't find it back as he and I and he
goes I go what happened and he goes that
guy was like you know making fun of me
like like and I saw you know me I saw
red yeah and so I go well now I have to
go fight this guy cuz he's a bad person
and he's at the Comedy Store which is my
spot
you can't come to my spot you can't make
fun of a [ __ ] good guy like this guy
what happens after ababy Wester yes
that's his name oh yeah with the gun oh
you're not alike thank you
I go you're not allowed to do that you
know I said to a comic one of our own
he's a comic he's got you know a
situation I was so like you can't
believe people like that exist you can't
believe they exist so I'm like alright
so now I gotta get got an extract an
apology otherwise he's he's gonna get
you know some we're gonna do some stuff
to him I walk up days with me and I
don't realize that as I start walking
all the other comics and they're all
misfits like just the misfits you know
the mists of the saying they follow me
so it's like that it's like the bar I've
seen from Star Wars they're all look
like you know it's like they're just not
the most they're a motley crew just I'm
not like what like the guys like where
do you live what do you do for a living
like nobody has any it's just and I
don't realize that they're all following
me so as I'm walking and the word says
what do you say we say we're spent so as
I get to the bar and this guy sitting
standing at the bar I go bro I go bro
you you got a problem here right you got
a problem which is that you made fun of
them so you got something to say I did
something like that
yeah and he turns and sees me I'm not
scary yeah but I look back and literally
every misfit from money is just
converging I've never seen anybody more
afraid of my life
because I was just joking around I was
just doing a cone food thing and he
thought I was and he came up with this
whole story all you have to do by the
way with is that with me because I don't
want to fight I just want you to give me
any excuse to walk away yeah like oh
yeah I was I was talking to James Bond
whatever I'll be like oh that sounds
like a good excuse not walk away but
then we killed him anyway we slew him
you did we slew him you beat him up we
can
and we can drain the body of blood we
headed up we and we and we dumped it at
sea so nobody can see so that's the one
time I killed somebody that's the story
that's the punchline teardrop about
killing is the part on the inside it's
no it's on your body so how do I get rid
of the body
it I've thought about that I watch like
snapped and stuff and people get caught
because they don't how to get rid of the
body so you you can burn it but they
always seem to find shards of bone
yeah they find bones drop attach you
have a tattoo of a drop up come at the
tip of your dick yes I did and you know
why that's ironic
well I don't drip I shoot [ __ ]
heavy arcs heavy arcs of what I call
glory and when I when I when I when I
when I lose it I go heavy arcs
heavy arcs of glory that's what I say
well I'd be mastering so much that
nothing really comes out even does up
with no a rising drop or something yeah
yeah and I was making love to kalila day
or night and you know how you say that
at sexy times and I was you know I
always announce it yeah I'm about the
car I make the girl announces yeah I'd
say tell me when you're coming out to
come cuz that makes me okay and it's
gonna come right with them I have that
you truck driving speculations yeah
welcome so I roll over thank you so I
roll over and you know how you should
start drinking all to come right all
right I don't I just I go yeah this all
belongs to you or I just say for now
congratulations but in French finsihed
Sto sorry that's just personal [ __ ] yeah
I do that you just gotta use guy gave
you a flashlight into my dark bedroom go
on rolled over never after you did that
you sound so sad you jerk off at your
table and I go uh I make the noise
right and literally nothing came out
yeah and she was watching me the whole
time yeah and then I heard are you as
you get older apparently as your process
throws the money shot goes away really
yeah I've been having trouble with my
money so I'm about to turn 50 - I'm 50
you are you're in better shape because
you don't drink it all right I mean you
know I'll have a little wine I'm into
Japanese whiskey lately
I like this such a thing ya know and and
suck it high high-end sake you're 50
yeah I'm literally about to be 52 and I
want people to send me presents I feel a
different and then any I feel a
difference like I feel tired more yeah
no I don't but but but you and I as I've
been growing older I think you don't
have to work as much work out as much as
you do I think that's what it is so I
think you have to do more things like
bicycle ride and play tennis walking
locks and it's a good a boxing part is
what I'm talking about if you saw me
play today I was good I don't mean just
are countless nobody was good I would
you'd say I suck
what's up yep did workouts as much as
you used to know you know because I now
walk and bike and swim yeah and I and I
don't I'm not tired and I sleep like a
baby I think though that I work out out
of a deep sense of insecurity like I
have to be ready for the apocalypse yeah
and you just want to look good
let less I think as I is I really get
deep into the psychology of it I feel
like I should be a vegetarian and just
do yoga and never probably feel better
yeah but no I have to box and I have to
do Olympic weightlifting somehow in my
mind first of all I think I'm gonna get
big that's never gonna happen - I feel
like I'm gonna be safer if I'm if I'm
strong and I'm still fighting it's all
really slow man ranked yeah it's not
that look it up because I think that you
need to settle down I need I'm feeling
it instinctively know I do yes you so
though he's got children he's got a wife
and everybody's just said he still works
out he still boxes and lifts Olympic
weight yeah yeah but by the way I love
it so much but I lift like I don't lift
a lot of weight I lift they would do
women there who train they lift more
weight than
what Jim I need a Venice barbel Club
yeah don't don't Andy that's so mean
seriously oh this is my show I don't
know yeah but that's always been your
thing we're at your court I think high
school right you were a fit lean
probably you know [ __ ] machine correct
yeah wrestler right I've already I was
on wrestling but I've always been this
guy crack you like my angle you would
have tried to try on me I know you would
of course you would have like a bruckman
soon as I got you see and you're gonna
give up a little guy Ralphie yep just a
couple no I'm a senior year sophomore
you want to be cool kid alright Andy my
copy Kirkland yeah is that how you [ __ ]
I don't know yeah I get to that point
yeah oh you do I have not [ __ ] in a
long time really what my last girlfriend
two years we met in rehab and we had a
horrible falling out she ghosted me and
I'm not over it it's been a year you're
not over it
no and then she'll she's so good at it
you damn girls she will call me or email
me
you know what ghosted it ghosted it's
just I can't reach her I can't see her
Instagram I can't email her can't call
her can't anything but every 2 or 3
months she'll give me a call
she'll FaceTime me so I can see her and
then she'll she'll tango she just did a
couple weeks ago like maybe even last
week she faced hired me and I asked her
I got right to and I said can I just can
I ask you one question when you
masturbate do you think of me that's a
she went oh she went yes damn it
exactly like that she said yes damn it
that and I don't know if she's telling
the truth
she's not no know what I mean Andy Andy
and she's just doing that and she's
[ __ ] [ __ ] with ya with your mind
yeah my car
you couldn't no law you got a disconnect
no but hold on here's my question this
is getting DC's hottest hold on she's
number will do you sure she she doesn't
want me to talk about her but she works
in politics in Washington DC
okay so can I ask you this question it's
like smart I'll ask you this question
go ahead but I doubt I'm she's gonna
ghost me for three years do you think
that your your need to feel 62 that
question speaks volumes because what
that question really means is which my
so yeah am I still relevant to you yeah
so in other words a sexual way yeah so
do you think that you are actually yeah
is it your attraction to her or is it
your need to stay relevant and powerful
still like oh it is her yeah she but
it's both because when I met her I was I
told her you're barking up the wrong
tree girl wise I'm trying to just be
with guys right now
because you girls [ __ ] me over you do
especially [ __ ] are you guys are in the
girls there you don't know I think girls
when I'm sober it's seems like girls
like I really want her back I really
really do I'm not kidding I haven't
[ __ ] in like a year yeah but then
you're drawn to a guy like a long time
you like Brendan cuz he's a big handsome
son that ain't gonna happen but what is
it about that that it's like yin and
yang and chin its chin and yang yeah
she's like it's like the opposites like
I want look at like she's perfect for me
but then when I when I'm with a man I
want to Vegas and best really yeah can I
ask you a very personal question with a
man's me do you want to bang bang no
nobody's ever [ __ ] me Oh see you like
to [ __ ] so so so so fascinating to me
because I can't fathom being attracted
to like that's such a fundamental
difference
your brain is complicated it is and can
I tell you something and I haven't
talked about this anywhere yeah hey I
appreciate that little when it's a
little weird but I met this girl and
this might have happened to you guys but
I met a girl I'm just gonna cut right to
it we went home and and I you know I was
around with her and she had a dick I
don't like what and I was you know I
just was confused and I kept playing
with her tits that were not fake they
weren't implants
she took estrogen so they actually grew
so that's what got me cuz I cuz I'm kind
of a tit guy so I was playing with her
just playing another I finally said okay
let's go down here what and I was
confused and I and she stayed overnight
and I was just confused all night I'd go
back and forth and it and I can't do
that again can't can't do it again it's
too complicates too much that's if you
can't do both did it did you did you did
you suck it suck the pee pee no I did it
okay
and I didn't let her suck mine no no we
just I was just have yeah you have you
suck pee pee before though of course
okay that's my little thing I say on
stage as I say I'm not gay
but I have been known to chomp down on a
snickerdoodle or toodle right help me
write this one if it if if I act gay and
I sound gay and I look gay does not mean
I'm a duck
I don't know I said help me write that
just because I act gay look gay sound
gay talk walk eh doesn't mean I'm a doc
yeah or did you get it it doesn't mean
I'm a duck but it does mean I [ __ ] guys
[Laughter]
that's the difference I don't I can't
yes you can I come up we're one of the
funnies and I tell story no just sit and
think I already told them about this
like two months ago when I didn't
[ __ ] pocket a yellow dome I go what
the [ __ ] you talking about man yeah I
think you can do it it's as his you
can't be negative bro I'm not negative
might be tries to sit down and write I
know that you're gonna you think I write
the way he does his jokes are so weird
that I could never write like hand off I
know I mean he does this like a fake
hockey thing on stage right these
monsters don't say it's not real no it's
real no it's real you know it's been
like the heart of so
when ever since news radio yeah you've
been like this since you used to hang
around Joe Rogan on the set I was
children's radio yeah and you were funny
back then and you've always been put
Bobby is so supportive of me I love him
we're on love together mm-hmm
the Nats like show love you guys you
love yeah we're on it together I didn't
know yeah he's on it without scenes
together but no weed and at one time
when I cover yeah and you know in the
scene you know what he said because my
name is Truman in the show you got any
in the scene he walks and he goes hi
Bobby I play it's Truman I'm sorry he's
my friend or something like that yeah
you guys watch any shows that you're
that you love oh yeah I do I watched
what's the left
well everybody watched stranger things
right I don't like it you know I didn't
speak to me and either did the Punisher
I watched some of that did Brenham song
I'm out
I like the shameless from Manchester the
English what a manchester the real one I
said great yeah no I only watch um naked
and afraid yeah I really like that a lot
and also there's no III think that I
could um be on that show you don't watch
G ot what's that Game of Thrones oh
that's my favorite
do ya you liked yield PM o throws yeah
it's so good University they people like
him it's weird so that's what I want you
never seen it it's weird you watch girl
shows yeah like I love to drop dead diva
Margaret Cho was on that I was right
name I was always on it twice but I
couldn't make it
Wow it's all the way in Atlanta could I
ask you something
wait you were cast Weiss and you just
didn't make it on time oh no you got
drunk I was I was having a bad ear candy
anyways what were you gonna say because
of all the things that are going on now
with the Kevin Spacey yeah there's
things that have you been editing your
behavior because I feel like I've been
editing mine yes yeah I I'll even take a
girl's hand and go you are so I'm sorry
my allowed to do that like I just make a
little joke yeah even it with the
slightest of touching or anything
like I was at the Comedy Store and you
know I usually grab this one guy's penis
all the time you know he's fine he cuz
he grabs mine too yeah which guy I can
tell you but um Turk but I went to go
grab it and then I went I pulled away
and if there was sadness about it yeah
you know because you can try I think you
can still be playful and I think you
know I just you know coming from the set
I was just on set with a bunch of
cheerleaders young young volleyball
player these gals and I just think it
comes down to like just respect and not
being an [ __ ] yeah you know yeah
there's the rare crazy person I was like
he touched my shoulder but for the most
part I think that just don't be a dick
like I well I was listening to somebody
who used to work on a certain show I
won't say what it is and they were
talking about how the men on that show
were treating the women and the extras
were being lined up there I get rid of
her she's not good-looking get rid of
her she's not gonna she's like I've
never done that in my office like when I
hear those stories and I hear about how
a lot of women had to deal with that
[ __ ]
or how about the fact that it was just
the order of the day that some some lech
is gonna [ __ ] with you and it's gonna be
exhausting I don't and I don't think you
should have to deal with that you know
and so for me like in that sense as I
think about that stuff I'm like I I
don't want to make anybody feel
embarrassed humiliated or less powerful
because I'm a dude and she's hot and
then she's got to deal with this [ __ ]
all the time and she's at work I don't
like that [ __ ] so man maybe it's good
you know a lot of the stuff I do think
that innocent heads are gonna roll I
think sometimes like louis c.k i think i
think he's innocent
well there's an overreaction I think
with Louie I don't know the stall the
situation but don't either if you're
gonna jerk off in front of people you
work with like I think then leave the
room they can say excuse me I blog I
think the fact whether that he was
blocking them I guess right no it wasn't
that for more than an hour because I
have to pee so bad oh well we compete
let's take let's take a pee break do you
breathe pee break
all right let's get back to it so let's
get back to Lewis I've seen your penis
when we're talking about a secret Ella
Ben no my thing about that is just that
if you are if somebody works for you
and you're a writer and you call them
into the office and you go to my to my
jerk-off the person goes if I say no
this is my boss what happens it's a
weird situation so then he jerks off and
you go that's really weird I didn't know
they they worked for him yeah
oh that would be some of the cases and
he said you know I was in a position of
power so I was putting them in a
position where they were the word yes
didn't really mean anything and that's
where you get into the issue also by the
way if you work with somebody here's an
idea
you just don't jerk off it's a higher
when you do a TV show trying to be
awesome and the extras you know it's
just not a good idea I got in trouble
once on that show I did less than
perfect I would never do it now yeah
all I did it's a good scene to watch the
extras and I slap them on the butt yeah
good good scene oh my god you do that
like instead of good game you know good
scene yeah and I got big trouble I'm
like dude oh well I think about all the
things as a young man you don't know
what your impact is you're just trying
to get laid you're flirting you know
you're upset when I was younger I was
reckless you're trying to pick up a girl
here try to pick you just like it's your
like I can do whatever I want
that's our generation yeah I wasn't
trying to hurt nobody here I was trying
to get a date all exactly yeah and
that's how I learned most of my dates or
because I was a little bit aggressive
right and they would tell me I liked it
and that's why I'm dating me
and I sometimes I was on that TV and I
got I had to get a lawyer because I
farted in Cristal Flanagan's mouth I
grabbed for a laugh she get you got suit
she was like oh yeah I had to get a
lawyer and or like an office and then I
think picked up a deposition and the
whole thing how did you get your [ __ ]
up to her mouth no what happened was
here's the problem I didn't know her so
this was the first day of work I didn't
know we hired a new actress on the show
Christa what does that have really worth
anything I don't know
you didn't hours so you're allowed to
fart Wow Kristin was married to Bill
Lawrence no and she was sitting on the
couch eating yogurt one morning during
rehearsals I didn't know that we had a
new actress so she was eating yogurt it
was so early you know y'all do 6:00 in
the morning like we're on stuff I was so
tired
and there's everyone's in the room
there's no personal room so I just
grabbed the back of her head and I and
as she was eating yogurt I farted in her
mouth you can't do that I know what I
did ever and that's the problem I did
and that's the problem and then I'll I
know but then then what happened was
that's I went home I took a nap and then
I woke up and I had like 20 messages and
they go you got to get a lawyer like why
and they go you farted in Crystal
Flanagan's mouthwash shooting eating
yogurt yeah and I go and what else did I
do nothing else yeah and then so then a
week later I'm in an office yeah and you
didn't rise because you were being goofy
right you are yours so I'm in an HTML
office what you know and I is what
happened somebody goes and had tape
recorded it and they go tell us exactly
what happened I go okay I walk in right
yeah I'm sure and I go she was sitting
there and she opening her mouth I grab
the back of her head and fart it you're
going to jail and then you hear like the
twenty second silence and from the back
of the room we hear wine and I go answer
then later that day put on a little
Asian accent when you're hello
so and then I ran into her on the lawn
so sorry
okay and I gave her a $500 gift
certificate to elaborate that's
appropriate the seaweed wrap the whole
[ __ ] thing yeah and then I got hail
so I just popular character at the time
like I wrote you in as a second lead you
know the first live that's more that's
better
oh yeah a massage place I think yeah and
then
became the best of friends okay when she
dropped the lawsuit yeah [ __ ] yeah good
smart of you that was so bad that I
would I can understand that's like you
grabbed me by the back there and I do
think rap women in one way or another
had to deal with weird [ __ ] like that at
one point another all the time like they
like I've talked to so many women who
are not like hysterics and and they're
like they go I've been dealing with that
[ __ ] like forever you know so you know
it's the first time in comedy you just I
just do things for the laugh and
sometimes I read the situation wrong
yeah I didn't I had an audition with
comedy suffers with this hysteria that's
the one thing like there's no more
comedy in the workplace yeah everybody's
terrified to do anything
I had this audition and this director he
was an african-american guy and he was
fat and I killed it
you know how you and then you know how
you do a good audition and then they go
stick around let me ask you some
questions you know that's when yeah why
you got this [ __ ] thing yeah so I was
talking like you're really good man
you're perfect for this and I was like
you know we're like laughing yeah and
while we're laughing he was fat I go
fatty like that damn it and it just
changed the room ah and then he's like
and he goes thank you like that and as I
was walking out I go and that's the job
why did I do it that I don't know why I
did that
by the way you know you're in the moment
you're laughing and then do something
that you would do to like Eric Griffin
to your friend Ralphie May or somebody
or that car that's a form of
self-sabotage like so consciously do you
think so yeah I think that's what you
did subconscious you go I've got most
got this part gotta ruin this I'll do
that just like Pillsbury Dough we all do
[ __ ] like that I've said things where
I'm like I can't believe I just did that
I know like I had a part for Sydney
who's the [ __ ] director he died of
love little man know that poor they want
to [ __ ] symbolic oh yeah and it was
just huge Kane and they brought me in
what I damn pain yeah it was a
commercial and Patterson all right and
they wanted me to and I
I stayed up all night like an idiot and
had it sabotage myself go in and I was
too tired to really you know hit all the
details yeah he wanted me to do little
things I would have killed it but not
had to ruin it would have been worth a
million dollars but you know what do
cocaine that night ah no but I believe
that was the night I had an orgy oh yeah
yeah that was a way yeah yeah that's
your drug by the way sex I know that
about you oh yeah sex good-looking dudes
like you though yeah I had to work for
my girls hard I had to work
I don't know you don't have to work you
are your guests and the LIA all these
guys thank you wait I had to put on a
mass amount of work you know I have to
like do different nice dinners different
angle what do I do the friend thing
listen to their stories the whole thing
I am can I tell you as this is the part
that nobody talks about this and I don't
know if this has happened to you guys
but it's happened a number of times to
me where I have been raped by a girl I'm
not kidding one time this is one time
yeah this is funny for you no I just
lined the victim you're the victim but I
don't mind because I'm like great yeah
I'm I'm not saying women should think
like this but a like oh I'm attractive
enough to for this woman to rape me
either I'm drunk or usually I am but in
this one instance the girl said get
behind me and then she reached under and
grabbed my dick from you know she was on
her knees and she used my heart dick to
just rub on herself yeah and then she
was just put in a little bit and then
keep rubbing until she came she's and
then she just jumped up and ran out and
I'm like okay what about me and she was
ran out ran out she was done she used my
dick like this so interesting Wow pretty
hot though
that's not but it really whoo that's not
right kind of rape she wouldn't ever let
me stick it in all the way because when
hand was at the base because you know
you're like you're like oh this is cool
yeah yeah raped an
that's great I love it I had a girl with
lemon raped you know that's right yeah I
think I've had girls who used me that
way yeah I've had a larger girls get on
top of me and that kind of Israel I
can't move that did they did they did
they they just got a mixer no they got
on top of me and just yeah
I have you I've eaten [ __ ] when I
didn't want to write socially I go I
haven't we all haven't had sex we didn't
want yeah I was in India I've had sex
when I didn't want to but I had I didn't
want to be rude yeah yeah yeah well what
am I gonna say no you're naked it would
be as a guy I'm a you know you're like
I'm not attracted to feel hobbling I
don't wanna hurt her feelings about me
and I'm sure women do the same field
that can I called regrettable sex yes
and by the way the the groping and
licking that I have done the majority of
it I'm not [ __ ] around here is
because I feel obligated like if I don't
they're gonna be mad yeah I'm not
kidding
yeah if I don't like this person or give
him well Mike my girl was 300 pounds
okay it was an Indiana yeah right and
Michael O'Connell said you have to do it
right so I get it yeah and I hoop goes
eat it that down there oh right and I
went down there and it smelled like hot
blood like curdled blood it's an issue
and it was like a [ __ ] NCIS scene it
was like you know like a homicide had
gone off yeah fresh yeah a fresh there
was a dead body right and I went down
there and I held my breath because I
didn't want to get in like in inhaler
that's a disaster yeah it's a disaster
and I said but then once you start
getting into it it starts tasting normal
yeah knows who that who the saltiness so
you did get used to what I heard an
expression I think that wonderful
I will fight 20 as he said when he the
first time he went down on her his young
guy the first time in my diner he said
she tasted like Heineken I was like wow
that makes sense nice she tasted like
Heineken I'm not gonna get at curdle
blood phrase and secret little blood
friend oh I thought you said the hot
blood but then you said Colonel Brett
hurdled he said Colonel I did a second
time yeah yeah you gotta know what you
say bro only only you know what I all I
own it I said curdled maybe it didn't
help to rewatch now I'm what when you
put your outfit on this morning I love
it this is what I didn't put your s is
why I can go ahead when you roll that I
better put those slippers on yeah yeah
so you can't be more comfortable than
Bobby at this point okay number one
number one can I just say some things
kid this is um a [ __ ] podcast yeah
who gives a [ __ ] bro bro you're on
camera I know I didn't realize it well
and also I at the end of the day yeah
you know I'm here because I'm your
friend
dude I would dress like that but Shaab
won't have it he actually fashion
bullies me and I just realized that
because I would come into flip-flops oh
yeah bro really
who is that hate it hurts him Brendan
Brendan Schaub dude
boxer in the kid I love oh the fighter
and he's a good dude all right you're an
MMA fighter yeah I do MMA is this studio
all just for you or do other people come
here no just for us for real that's the
other thing Brendan won't have this is
all Brendan Brendan will be like this we
were at Fox and and Brennan we were we
were oh I see the fighter duck we had a
studio we had studio no and now the
people would use it and Brendan I see
Brendan he's just he's got his arms full
of these just looking at the mics I go
what's up he goes other people using the
studio so man I know but whatever he
goes drives me nuts
I like he's competitive I like this I
like this what the [ __ ] is that
we had a guy coming into the mural yeah
I don't like that this is cool yeah hey
you [ __ ] that's really good you paint
that did you paint that like that no I
don't like it well guys I'm sorry I
think it's good
do I have a whole the whole Bobby Bobby
you don't you don't do any you don't do
a lot of working out no no no why not
because um I just I don't have time for
it in my life what that is the big and
I'm in big trouble
I'm in big physical trouble right now
dude what's going away
what's calais I have um so I got a sick
I got sick a month ago and then I
couldn't hear okay I went completely
deaf in my right ear oh my god you got
so fat it the fat was a nurse I got sick
I didn't say fat so you had inflammation
or something it was a block it was like
an infection in my ear and I come back
in both ears no just one my right one
okay okay do it but it was cool when I
went to sleep because I was sleep on my
left ear
it was completely that sign it was great
but that you know yeah
but then what happened was um you're not
gonna believe this you're not gonna
[ __ ] believe girl hold on so I'm
sleeping on my left ear and I came here
on my right ear right
and I I was my last week of um the show
that I was shooting a be know ABC I'm on
an ABC show splitting up together yeah
and um I had a 6:00 in the morning
called time so I'm sleeping on my left
ear and I hear hello in my house and I
go what the [ __ ] I wake up and go to
kalila if there is so I pick up on a
stick I have a stick like I cystic it's
a back scratcher thing but really Erdem
there's nothing else there a back care
for I'll scratch you I swear to God and
I walk into the living room it's a guy
from the shows that your alarm you
didn't like the AZ the second a almost
10 second ad and she goes gate whatever
you're wearing now we're going I left in
what I slept in and I'm walking to the
car go oh so sorry like that and I get
to the arm side and they had to do
everyone's coverage you know um it's the
biggest that's a nightmare never [ __ ]
have to you've done that too for many
times but I've only I've never done I
don't know how he got into my house yeah
because we don't leave it locked
he was the problem-solver he solved it
in the building I don't know how in the
house that's one thing because I live in
a condo you've been there and um it
would and then I had to apologize for
executive producers
I'm so sorry that's never happened
before alright but just don't let it
happen again but it was like oh my god
what a nightmare
did you tell me you're definitely yeah I
can't hear like this like this so then I
went and got antibiotics and it's all
cleared up knocking okay and that's so
but but you're fine now no no and then I
had stroke level high blood pressure
Oh big oh you could yeah you have you
could have a stroke at any minute
do you eat crappy yeah all you need to
do is start now he's gonna make me mad
eight doughnuts all the time hold on
it's all I had one yesterday you on it
so you're on medication now yeah I have
a blood pleasure okay so can you would
like are you just gonna be a dick and
not doing or maybe your exercise I just
[ __ ] told you I'm on blood blood
blood blood Medicaid yeah but will you
eat better now no no it's not gonna
watch it now I hate people who say I
hate you I hate you all judgy put your
finger in my face yeah you know me I
live I'm gonna do something right now
better right now let me see something
right now I come on dude don't be a
[ __ ] that workout and makes all you
ever do is walk walk walk for an hour
and editing and [ __ ] eat a little
better not walk with you once a week
yeah we can go on we can go around the
lake hockey and walking with you bro
this tops up he's insulting obviously
right now to Andy right right yeah I
ain't walking with you know where where
what's your problem that's my problem I
like you dude but let me tell you this
right now there it goes
me not working with you nowhere hey why
are you talking that way because I want
to all right bro why don't you walk in
hey why don't you go walk in the what do
you got I mean briar that'll never
happen Frank you don't but you first you
had the bullhorns turn into a gun I'll
go to a club with you what is that man
walking nowhere with you bro oh yeah he
gave you the horns and then the pistol
he gave you the horns that I just wanna
walk it has nothing to do with me you
know you right I'll never walk with you
wera Fred I love you too I really truly
love you why wouldn't you walk with I'll
walk down a busy street like on the
Grove Street Promenade money can I make
you some make me some money to you why
do you bring recording equipment to mics
go on your walk and call it call the
podcast the walk and whatever happens on
the walk they run into people you
interview them talk about things that
you call it whether other doesn't need
people walking with us hey bro I love
this guy [ __ ] you man quit I quit the
podcast with you right now quit he gave
me a pop he's got the six shooters out
now whatever you do don't point your dog
doesn't need a podcast he has a new show
on ABC is it out yet in March I play on
who told me it was funny you know you
don't [ __ ] rude that you would even
say something like I meant Kareem he
said something right now man I have no
accent in it
there's no references to the me being
Asian I'm just a regular American so
that's not realistic then why I don't
believe Asians should be in the business
I just mean be in front of a camp yeah
yeah you we should to be directing the
kygo your stunt double yes but you know
how big be but you know what um all
jokes aside um I'm just really blessed
right now man I know to be here can I
ask you a question yeah
in 30 years when you're 70 whatever the
[ __ ] I'm not gonna make it till then
okay but if you do what do you want to
be doing well I want to be um I want to
be involved in in video games still so
be telling that yeah oh you mean playing
yeah I play video games all the time
oh I don't move I think that's the
problem with the doctor said doctors you
don't move
yeah that's a problem and I always sit
like this you know I mean and it's like
so like a Buddha whatever a Gabe you
gotta move rakia man hey friend like a
Buddha sorry man yeah you like a
butterfly his toenails are his legs are
gonna flap and he's gonna be well pops
his toenails would drag along the ground
you just hear what time I walk those
little organelles I've ever seen
yeah no Annie what do you wanna be doing
when you're 70 besides banging guys and
girls I that okay I really would like to
have my sex life be intact and very
active all the way up to 100 okay but I
thought about Dick Van Dyke this morning
two things I thought about this morning
when I was meditating one of them is
Dick Van Dyke he had a drinking problem
cleaned up and then he started doing
what was it called what was that
detective show called murder murder she
wrote no but that's another one Angela
Lansbury lit later on Ironside Oh later
on in life when he's like 70 he's still
acting yes he was you know and he's not
drinking anymore through ice and I
thought about him on that show but but
the other thing I thought about was you
I thought about you and I've never seen
you with long hair I don't know what I
thought about it I think I was thinking
about my gray hair I was thinking do it
does it turn into like an ass yeah it's
terrible doesn't have to be so cool it
doesn't know it looks me bad it looks
like [ __ ] it grows up and and breaks off
I think it's called murder 101 which a
hair like Isaac oh he's got good hair
diagnosis murder
you remember that diagnosis I read the
books III want to I'll be honest with
you at 70 I want to feel like I'm still
relevant you will be no because you know
you're coming into your own right now
about Bing Crosby and when he was like
70 a kid walked up to him and said
didn't you used to be Bing Crosby and he
in it shattered his heart he's a bad guy
you know that he was a real piece of
[ __ ] they committed soon as they make
sure I'm hey I'm real quick Brian do you
dye your hair
no so you don't have gray hair not me
I've never dyed my hair yeah your dice
is part of my beard I've never done this
you have a little grace yeah I never
done look okay I used to because my
girlfriend made me and I was this
morning I was thinking of your hair
because I was thinking of mine thing and
maybe I should go back to dyeing it yeah
Bing Crosby so adenosine appearances who
of them so just wonderful what did Bing
Crosby die of right there right up there
on just hate his first words yeah right
there one
hardac look okay yeah I think Dixie Lee
committed to his wife and his son
biggest star do you know that oh yeah he
used to be like bigger than like Houston
or Madonna awful both the two sons
committed suicide but he was apparently
a terrible father Michaels awful abusive
and alone and then disowned them and all
that but I don't know what I was I don't
know we don't know yeah like a good guy
in the documentary I live with all my
kids all of them and my stepkids I'm the
only adult suppose an adult and you know
whenever I meet your kids and like I've
met your kids and they go oh I'm Andy
Dick's daughter or son I always go wow
that's not what I thought it would turn
out to be get there there's so good
people no no no no it's because the mom
know you're going to you're a great guy
but they're not you know I never hit him
and I never yell at them yeah they're
just really good you're all very loving
you're a really good guy that's what I'm
saying yeah and you're angry about it
you're you're you're almost you're not
loving
this guy your special guy your company
asked me if I was autistic on my
periscope the smiley I think I'm in
spectrum I really yeah but you're also
you're also [ __ ] hilarious hey you've
been working forever
30 years and and you and you are but you
you like drinking I love how you drink
you hit great are you not sober right
now no I'm sober you are how long I
don't have it on my app I don't like
looking at it I'll go get two points but
more than a week yeah oh it's like a
month or so I don't want to look cuz I
know disappoints I just could I just ask
because I'm sober I've been I know and
like I I want Andy to be sober and when
he goes out and I hear what he goes out
it [ __ ] breaks my [ __ ] heart every
[ __ ] time why God's doing that
because I decide what when I'm I'll tell
you why because you know take one dome
oh no I didn't know that yeah yeah Oh
see you're are you a master yeah I am
okay I was born with it you know they
only talk one no cuz that's Korean I
know it's the only move I know that you
don't study comforting but my point is
is this that I just I want you to stay
in it can't you take a drug that helps
with drinking a mace you know I know you
have yeah yeah there's a new rehab in
Venice near here where they use
marijuana you're allowed to smoke or
take edibles that's good I don't want to
do no I don't think that's gonna work
you all right yeah yeah let's go to some
current events oh yeah how long is this
goddamn podcast done you got places to
be I have to be on a plane are you going
to join Stan chuckle so write Sharma
improv alright I do it every year
Thursday Friday Saturday's my fit dude
companies that go out much team make in
a weekend both of you mm-hmm would you
make a number of times how many zeros
and ran $20 I'll be honest in Schaumburg
I make about sounds I do 20 oh no not a
hundred grand yeah 28,000 maybe I don't
make that much that's a lot do you make
that much money hey Haskell don't
[ __ ] tell me ass
ask well you should tell Tony you should
tell Tony be reasonable it just had
Bobby Lee on the show and I want to make
what he makes you gotta get like I'll
tell you something right now on wine and
in Schaumburg those are the only two
clubs that I make that kind of I will
see how much I make this I think right
now I'd be surprised because I think now
because honestly I like just said this
yesterday when I said I was gonna do
this she goes that dude right now is
absolutely killing it you really are
[ __ ] that you a disc this thing yeah
it's how I turn the kids this thing the
pot on the kids right it's really in
your Brandon kid Brandon you guys really
[ __ ] this random friend this is
probably the best podcast right now go
going well it's good is it number one it
or not we got over 10 million downloads
a month
oh [ __ ] god [ __ ] yeah and then I'm
gonna go person I just stand up alright
guys well can i plug mine real quick um
if you kind of like what I'm doing Tiger
belly Tiger belly's fine thank you what
is that it's my podcast and we gotta get
you on oh yeah please do here we're
sorry you stand boys yeah I'm like this
is it when does this air tomorrow so
just weaken them and I plugged some
stuff yes this I'm gonna be good go
ahead spin it that's why I don't [ __ ] a
hike with you oh [ __ ] bro come on I
thought you were done what are you doing
this weekend I want to be in the Oxnard
levity live and because of the fires
that went on god bless you and I hope my
prayers are with you oh but you're not
gonna give him the money like that club
I really see it being real and I have my
heart's on to you that's a great club
but yeah but because of the fires and
whatnot I'm we're a little worried about
the numbers so I want to say this okay
I'm gonna give you fire victims anyone
that's involved in the fire after the
show I'm gonna give you a hug thank you
were you gonna be well later this
afternoon I'm gonna be eating a salmon
Caesar salad in my kitchen good
okay good button for salmon any season
then I don't know what's up tomorrow you
know I never know I leave it up in here
no no there's real how I've been doing
because I'm as I coined the phrase gray
listed because I'm not blacklisted I'm
getting little offers here in your
holding pattern exactly yeah
they literally say just stay put what
yeah what push devil what my groping and
husband right no no my groping and
licking is just not that relevant it
almost made me mad like wait I want to
be number one yeah I want to be I want
to be the rapist pedophile like all
these other people that pushed me down
and now there's a long line now it I'm
not even on the list anymore weird but
I've been on blast for thirty years so
I'm used to it when all these things
came in I'm like nobody ever for me he's
harmless
and he like nobody was like you know
yeah but but you know I've had I've had
so many lawsuits and [ __ ] yeah how do
you deal with lawsuits I'm always like
oh I'm sorry
yeah I'm sorry I probably did lick your
face or whatever and I did I you know
and I just paid yeah it's horrible
you paid yeah how much do you think
you've paid that not a lot I know a lot
yeah like hotter Graham oh it would be
here in here in here near here but so
yeah at least not or anything but a lot
of different people so much stress
little weird things like farting in
someone's mouth things like that yeah
like you got out of it you you gave her
Burke Williams gift certificate yeah
yeah I wish I hit it and you want a
brand out of it and you made it and um I
I honestly my from here on out I'm
living a Christian life I can't believe
I'm not grabbing no more genital me
either I'm not and I want to say this
about a Christian life if you don't
accept Jesus in your heart you're gonna
favorite and hold your hand in a fire
and just know that that's what you'll
deal with for eternity
okay no way but I didn't finish so so
because I'm gray listed I've been doing
periscope because I found out that
periscope pays you know if you have a
certain amount of what's called stars
you have to have so many hearts that
turn into stars and I have them you know
they're just pouring
and I'm making very little I can
actually buy that salmon Caesar salad
I'm gonna have later today I'll have to
beg you guys take my lunch money thank
you
and then Tim Sabian from Howard Stern he
was his producer for the whole time he
made Howard quit a year ago he called me
two days ago and he is offering me
something at twitch.tv up here to that
it's the gaming yeah thing but they're
expanding I guess Amazon bought twitch
and you guys should look into it because
they want to do real programming like
talk shows and stuff like this
Wow you don't need you have ABC which is
Disney I get one job and now you're
rubbing in my face guys know it's such a
good Bing and I hope it goes forever
like at least five years because you'll
be set by a piece of property you know I
heard it which is awesome ABC wait are
you saying this twitch TV thing on
Google come on I gotta go the first one
Keaton Jones the kid that's making he's
going viral like crazy because of the
holding stuff did you hear about that
guy so it was all a lie oh no no it's
not a lot I don't know what it is out
that his mom might might be racist yeah
well why she has a confederate flag
that's very common in the south that
doesn't mean she's so there's more to it
though oh well there yeah the clarify
she said the same face she did it more
for like irony and she posted she's in
hiding now but why this is what you
posted on that
that's an order flag that we're down
there if you aren't bleeding no bones
are sticking out and you can breathe
stop crying for the for the love some
[ __ ] I think you for the love of God
some folks clearly never picked a switch
and before we all start talking to me
about metaphorical emotional financial
or historical blood and brokeness
don't join a group so this was after she
posted right after the Charlottesville
stuff that's why they're there
connecting the two and just recently if
you aren't bleeding no bones or
sticking out and you can breathe I stop
I don't really you know what I mean all
right you know but because of that the
donations some it was actually an Asian
guy made a GoFundMe page yeah dedicated
to the kid to save versus college fund
yeah and then it got up to like sixty
thousand whatever and then they stopped
it as soon as this stuff came out yeah
it's investing me a lot of money at
least no she didn't get it yet so she's
not even coming oh the GoFundMe people
stopped it yeah him the guy that made
and the GoFundMe people stopped it so
they can investigate it and then today
came out that his dad was actually a
white supremacist but he's like a
long-lost dad he hasn't been there for
years he looks like one I mean he's uh
yeah that's his hair dryer Aryan pride I
know but that's his dad that he doesn't
talk to and you know this white pure
police has got a great body all right
you're a pure-breed bro okay I love guys
like that it really by the way though
this has them do the kid gets bullied I
feel sure that's what they're saying so
the guy that made the GoFundMe said this
is not about the mom not anything else
is for the kid so almost like the kid
will get the money I'm a little afraid
of this let's move on to the next one
well they'll don't come and they'll find
us
there's a woman that screamed on a plane
recently yep I'm in Sacramento I saw
this yeah she was she went ballistic
she went realistic let's turn it up
[Music]
no no this thing's finicky listen right
yeah she's in jail yeah he's gonna go
for that
she's having a moment some people
freaked out she had a kiss yet anxiety
from she needed to smoke they kicked off
her smoking kicked out of the bathroom
cuz she tampered with the smoke detector
and then she was trying to smoke and
they said you can't do it and then took
it to her seat she freaked out and she
said later on that's not her she was
freaking out from anxiety as she needed
to smoke so though she was like yeah we
don't let me know from jail she said it
I don't know what would I do under the
bus I've ape on the plane yeah I'm vape
on the plane and no one ever says
anything can we do the Artie Lange one
and do the dad kicking the toddler no ok
well now oh he snorted you ideas now he
snorted glass by accident and his nose
got on no no he had surgery had surgery
so I missed a court appearance and
that's why he was arrested I love Artie
I feel why would he take her loving -
don't you love him he's my that's like
what about that was a great podcast you
do really know he was probably was
probably just kicking him cuz he was
like lying there throwing a 10 well I
want to see how hard he's gonna give him
a nudge pity
yeah you saw it yeah
oh my God look at how an old alright
you've been a Howard a lot right yeah
yeah but then we had a big falling out
but I don't know I still liked him I saw
him at Ben Stiller's 50th party a couple
years ago and Judd Apatow said you got
and he dragged me over to Howard and
said just just apologize you know I'm
like I'm so sorry I hope
you know everything's water under the
bridge and I really like and I've always
liked it I'm just I'm sorry for whatever
I'm sorry I called you a pig peep nosed
dip so did Eric I wasn't drunk I got I
was drunk with rage on Greg Fitzsimmons
show and Greg is good at at pushing
buttons and I got her all worked up and
I mean oh yeah well he's just and did
you did he accept your part
well he just kept saying this he said it
like three to five times it's like I'm
just glad you're taking care of yourself
nobody but I really want your good
blessings and I I please I I really like
you and I'd love to do the show again or
whatever you want to well what can I do
to make it up to you I'm just glad you'd
take good care good answer
you know he didn't at all and I said
well if that's the best I get from him
that I gotta live with it yeah I like it
what am i given I was like groveling all
right like you're honest now as we go
for a walk Bobby Bobby you're doing that
you're doing let me tell you something
right now [ __ ] you're doing a
podcast called the walk with Andy Dick
and I'll make you do it he'll pay for it
you'll produce it
yeah be I'll be your producer you'll see
it my life do it if I produce it get
ready for it - I just realize I need
help yeah let's do it I really do need
help and I don't want to die
it's - Bobby just take action don't be a
baby about things just small little
actions don't go oh my god just like
those other things like Rocky guide you
got here to do the podcast and look like
Ralphie May though what's the next
current event Oh your buddy John Stamos
at 54
oh no I boy has his very first baby hey
Johnny he's such a handsome guy and he's
a nice guy
yeah it sounds great guys can have kids
up into their seventies oh yeah it's the
girls that you know yeah their womb
drops to the floor or whatever that's
right happens I don't know
you know Tabak kids for him that's gonna
be a cute baby yeah John how old is the
woman Kate 31 settle that's done sir
well done well done he did it right yes
he did
yes I should have lots of money 50 so
got all his hair yeah plays with the
Beach Boys by the way completed piano
sing and the drums like the best of them
Dear John Stamos yeah does a weekly
thing it is like as good as it gets
yeah oh my on Broadway I mean he's great
people think he's just a guy from full
house now yeah the cute guy he can sing
like that I think he's nazi-like for
well we gotta get John on the [ __ ]
pot yeah get him okay next did you guys
know George Clooney gave 48 of his
closest friends a million dollars each
no he did no he did yes god damn George
why don't do a surprise dinner and just
and they paid for their taxes for the
year I love him oh my god that pisses I
wish he God dear God dear God if you
give me that I'll give twenty friends a
million dollars dear God please let me
be one of George Clooney's best friends
we have to pay back all the people that
took care of him
wow that's a million [ __ ] dollars I
love George Clooney man that he's in my
favorite now fast
I thought you were gonna say the one
that happened I think yesterday were on
an airplane yes him and his wife gave
out my headphones everyone on the plane
because there was a couple of crying
twins so he bought headphones and gave
them all out to everyone no came out to
drown out the crying only first class
dude he had them come to his house
they're all sitting there there's and
there's a bag a black designer luggage
bag at each place setting on the table
they open the bags they found a million
dollars in $20 bill do that so you're
talking about cash no taxes of course
taxes no no he said he that he paid for
the taxes that's ridiculous oh my how
much money does he have a million this
is a hoax so no he probably invested it
well he is his money made wait wait
Gerber got one too what Gerber doesn't
need the money
excuse me
Gerber brandy grabbers the owns that
Mondrian and all that oh he's saying I
said he Crawford's husband Jesus the way
he's awesome men he might be in finance
you gotta love George Clooney oh yeah
he's a class act
yeah I'm hung out with him a couple
times he would just be sitting at the
bar the cross from CBS because he was
doing his show there or something he'd
just be sitting there alone
and I would just saddle up next to him
you guys would talk yeah he's super just
nice down-to-earth guy yeah well next
yeah that's incredible how you do too
I need you would do you need I think you
would do to you would I want to I want I
want
arrogance I want a million dollars I how
can I become friends with him and do him
a favor all right keep going you want
happy stories that's so sorry what let's
hear what alternate one messed up one
now one messed up Chinese yes got what I
want
yeah like a Chinese daredevil oh yeah he
filmed his own death like live stream I
watched it and he I don't think he meant
to die no he lost his grip he lost his
grip and he died for doing that thing he
was said weld to win $15,000 from like
an unknown sponsor he was trying to do
pull-ups on the side of a building
62 floors oh he's not being Chinese he
didn't do the research he wasn't
diligent no he was really careful about
his planning but he did a few but it's
gonna happen right yeah eventually
you're gonna [ __ ] fall oh my god
anyone probably died before he hit the
pavement heart attack terrified
terrified it's not really Chinese
because if we could walk on a roofless
stuff we you're not what does that mean
you're crouching they have kung fu
powers yeah yeah not really easy with
those often I would have done I'll go on
a tree and I'm gonna roof the hobby you
don't have cool foo power either Coco
you don't have cool power
yeah next let's end on a happy note or a
happy note mmm this story an honest
donor bought every single Toyota at a
certain goodwill and the terminal area
or Toyota goodwill what do you spend 32
bucks yeah alright guys come see me at
the shop I want to thank two of the
funniest people on planet Bobby Lee and
auntie dick for love kid you guys are
awesome I'm gonna go do some deadlifting
and spike my testosterone I'm gonna go
do a ADR follow me on periscope follow
Andy on periscope how do they what is
your thing it's just Andy Dick
Andy - Harris Coe Bobbie what you have
Tiger belly Bobby Lee live on Twitter
and Instagram and Bobbie and then Tiger
belly there it is this is the butter and
the kid we're out